Santiago Tina boluarte es la primera
mujer en la historia de este país en
ocupar el cargo de presidenta
60 años abogada de profesión viene del
Perú profundo como se dice acá de la
región de Apurímac
un mucha pobreza ella ha sido enfática
al señalar sus orígenes muy Humildes se
ha dicho que tiene el compromiso con el
país con los peruanos con la democracia
y quiere tratar de sacar adelante este
Perú traen el estancamiento económico
tras varios meses de situación política
por motivo de la crisis este país se
encuentra en constantes conflictos Tina
boluarte ha prometido hacer un gobierno
de diálogo y va a depender mucho de los
puentes que ella atienda con el
parlamento sobre todo con los partidos
políticos en especial la derecha porque
el congreso de Perú la le ha suspendido
una investigación que tiene contra ella
por supuesto tráficos de influencias
vamos a ver si viene boluarte logra
consensuar con todas las fuerzas
políticas y realizar un gobierno hasta
el año 2026